what do you want to say to canadians now
who are having maybe a hard time
understanding
why the truckers and the people who
support them are so
you know are so committed to this
position what do you want to say to the
truckers themselves oh to the truckers
keep your heads gems
don't take the bait
you know what you're doing
producing a community there cleaning up
the streets trying to care for the
homeless
keeping a playful spirit about this
that's crucial
you know to to do it with this with with
a sense of play that's that's a sign of
mastery it's very difficult thing to
attain
and
don't let your frustration translate
itself into into violence
be careful be careful be careful there's
a lot resting on what you do every
single one of you yeah yeah so eyes open
like ethical stance forward
caution bravery truth
care
[Music]
uh hi everyone welcome julie panesi here
uh it's my absolute pleasure i'm so
honored to be joined by jordan peterson
today
who i think will have some very
interesting insights into the current
situation that's happening in ottawa of
course there are a great many things
going on today very scary days
this moment i think is electrified
it will be seen as electrifying in human
history there are many things we could
talk about but what's really punctuated
today is the situation that's developing
by the day by the hour in ottawa so
thank you so so much jordan uh for
joining us today and i should say i
think anyone who bothered to click on
this interview probably knows who you
are already and you don't need much of
an introduction we could easily give a
list of your you know academic and and
professional accomplishments but what i
really think of when i think of you
are two different things one is um you
have brought
intellectualism into the public sphere
in the best possible way
and secondly you are as far as i can
tell
unwaveringly and fearlessly dedicated to
ideas to following those ideas to their
logical conclusions i've seen you say on
many occasions that i don't know
to apologize when you when you air
um
but i think you are um you are
unapologetic in your pursuit of the
truth and depth and insight and you are
uncancelable and you are heroic in that
and we need that voice in this very
difficult concerning situation so i'd
like to start there let's welcome thank
you for joining us let's talk about
heroism for a minute
um because the truckers in ottawa and
those supporting them have been called
heroes by people supporting them and and
sort of on the anti-mandate side but
they've also been called things like
terrorists
on the other side which is it do you
think
well i guess we're gonna find out as the
weeks progress
because it's a constant
choice
you know and it seems to me that the
truckers and the protesters that
accompany them by and large have been
making the right choice this the
demonstrations have remained peaceful
they're not taking the bait and we'll
see what happens this weekend because
they're going to be under they're going
to be increasingly provoked as the
political situation becomes increasingly
unmanageable for
all for the people who are insisting
that the mandates stay in place
with no good reason as far as i can tell
the data seem to be fairly convincing
and i think have been actually for
several months that omicron is a rather
serious flu and no more than that and
the johns hopkins study that was
released the other day seems to
indicate quite clearly that lockdowns
didn't have the desired effect on
mortality now people are criticizing the
study and saying well that wasn't the
only positive effect it's like yeah
but you suspended our fundamental civil
liberties so let's go to the hard data
shall we and we certainly haven't paid
the price for the lockdowns yet not by
any stretch of the imagination
so
we'll see i'm i hope the truckers keep
their head and
and and maintain peace and civility in
the most cautious of manners because it
is a tinderbox and
in
when you're all
sitting inside a tinderbox it only takes
one idiot to light a match
so
you know the word hero comes from the
greek for defender or protector and that
is sort of the opposite of a terrorist
isn't it so it'll be very interesting to
see
how this goes
you know i can't get out of my mind it's
this idea has really gotten a grip on me
the last few days
that this trucker convoy
is the single most powerful
resistance we might call it that the
canadian people will be capable of to
challenge these
mandates um
yeah and it's a grassroots thing which
is so interesting watching the ndp react
to this it's so stunning to me that
elon musk tweets out in favor of the
truckers and yag meets singh
who's
an actor unparalleled in his falseness
perhaps only by trudeau
has so clearly indicated how little he
wants to do with the working class
it's something remarkable to behold and
i mean the truckers
aren't
making an articulate protest in some
sense right they're there with their
trucks that's their protest they're
they're standing their ground and
they've had enough of the assault on our
fundamental freedoms essentially and
it's up to leaders like trudeau and
singh and the conservatives
to articulate those voices and to bring
them forward peacefully and to attend to
them instead of demonizing them and
and then doing these unbelievably
appalling
maneuvers
first of all
focusing on the confederate flag
and the mainstream media is absolutely
complicit in this it's like that is so
preposterous that it barely
it's so surreal it's hard to believe
it's even true
as if the confederate flag has anything
to do with canadian history as if it
ever has as if there's people rallying
behind that some important sense
the same thing can be said
about the single swastika flag which is
one too many obviously and the idea that
the terry fox statue was desecrated
compared to say what happened to the
john a macdonald statue people should
have kept their boxes yeah absolutely
people should have kept their mitts off
the terry fox statue obviously but i
understand the truckers have put guard
around it now and
the what the legacy media is doing with
the trucker protest is beyond
reprehensible i think the most dangerous
thing i've seen actually
is the
political attempts to shut down the
gofundme funding that's that's
unparalleled
i think that's an unparalleled act in
canadian history i truly think that's
the worst thing that's happened to us so
far
you know
i'm constantly surprised
i i'm not i'm not by nature a cynic you
know really
and i'm not cynical about our public
institutions and generally although not
invariably i'm not cynical about
politicians
but
the the act of sheer
short-sighted
narcissistic
self-righteous
idiocy that went into blocking the
gofundme funding is i just can't believe
that i cannot believe that our
political leadership can be that
unconcerned even about their own
well-being
what sort of precedent does this set
and and it's basically a form of theft
collusion between a fairly large
corporate entity gofundme and the
government it's like collusion between
the government and the press which is
almost total now in canada
and i don't say that lightly i mean
brian peckford who i interviewed on my
youtube channel about a week and a half
ago who was a mainstream is a mainstream
political figure and one of the drafters
of the canadian charter of rights like a
respectable guy and was never a radical
relatively well regarded by the left and
the right alike in the 1980s a solid guy
told me flat out that the reason that he
announced his
legal challenge to the
authority of our government
on my youtube channel was because he
didn't think that he could get
the truth told about what he was doing
by any reliable canadian news outlet
and that's and that's just
what do you what do you do with someone
like that says something like that to
you it's beyond comprehension well i was
going to ask you what do you do when you
feel that um our main
media outlets are not accurately
reporting a situation it's interesting
because our experiences are very
different you haven't been in ottawa or
in canada since this started right so
you have a perspective only that's
coming through various kinds of media
and other sorts of information sources i
was there sunday through tuesday and i
have to say that being there and i can
say i had my young daughter with me
out walking on the streets talking
with truckers and
i didn't feel afraid
one moment um i didn't see most of them
now i'm not you know i wasn't every
place at every moment of course
um but i did not
what i'm seeing reported uh you know in
ctv and global and
cbc it's like a parallel realities it's
a planned no worse than that it's a
planned parallel reality which is
fundamentally equivalent to a
totalitarian encroachment i mean cbc
should be shut down canadians should
just say enough there's there's there's
absolutely no excuse whatsoever for
another single dollar of canadian
taxpayer money to go to support that
appallingly corrupt ideologically uh
warped politically correct collusionary
media source with the federal government
it's inexcusable and the rest of the
media well it's part of their
pronounced death spiral you see a little
exception to that
the toronto sun has had some decent
reporting you see it pop up now and then
in the national post you see it pop up
now and then even in the globe and mail
but by and large it's almost impossible
to see what's actually going on in
ottawa you can't even get a reasonable
estimate of the number of people there
and i've also
heard let's say that this close
circuit cameras that normally monitor
the city
which i believe you can get access to by
public feed many of them have been shut
off
it's like
you know now is that true is it not true
i don't know if it's true it wouldn't
surprise me but it's also if it is true
it's also
well it's beyond
it's beyond my capacity to imagine that
we're in this situation
isn't it all feeling just a bit
dystopian to you or a lot dystopian that
you know friday the police were talking
about doing digital tracking and now
protesting isn't allowed and the prime
minister is describing the supporters as
uh abuse and racism and um money is
talking about gofundme money is being
taken sexism and islamophobia every
bloody playbook in the radical left in
the in the radical left lexicon it's
like
you dare to drive your trucks to ottawa
to oppose our
possibly illegal mandates probably
illegal mandates
what's wrong with you you must be all of
these terrible things and and then let's
get the press in on it too and then you
know i would hope that the conservatives
for their part would stand up in some
sort of opposition but i know full well
because i've talked to people who know
um that
kovitt policy has been governed entirely
by public opinion poll which is a
terrible way of sampling public opinion
because it's impulsive and
narrow which is why we have a
parliamentary system to begin with we
don't have rule by direct democracy
because it's foolish it doesn't require
allow for any sober second thought let's
say and so
the politicians scare the public and
they do that with the collusion of
psychologists and behavioral experts
scare them into compliance and so then
they're all scared and then they sample
public opinion which is terrified by
misinformation and say oh look people
support more mandates and that scares
them further and away we go and the
conservatives for their part instead of
although mo and kenny have taken some
more forthright actions in the last week
instead of seizing the moment which they
clearly had in front of them they just
blew their party into fragments like on
the very day they should have been
articulating the concerns of the people
that they are
supposed to represent and and they could
have capitalized on that even in the
narrow political sense it's just beyond
comprehension
let's let's talk about democracy for a
minute we know that the prime minister's
office has made it very clear that it
the prime minister will not speak with
the truckers and up to this point
o'toole also decided not to speak with
the truckers now we have new leadership
in the conservative party um
what kind of act of democracy is that do
you think
and is there an obligation on the part
of our leaders
to respond to protests
well it's tough one right because it's
very hard to discriminate between
protest and extortion in some sense
right and we can't have a situation
where
merely by creating a civil disturbance
you get access to the highest levels of
leadership
but by the same token
i would say that the fact of the scale
of this protest and its seriousness is
an indication of a breakdown in
communication between the populace and
their leaders and then i would say
there's a twofold reason for that one is
the politicians have ensconced
themselves in something resembling an
ivory tower and are not in direct
contact with their constituents in the
way that they're morally obligated to be
in contact and then
there's a failure on the part of the
canadian populace as well because one of
the things that's happened over the last
three four five decades maybe
is a continuing
in civic engagement on the part of the
populace this cynicism about the
political sphere the refusal to engage
in the building of
local civic institutions
all replaced by a notion that politics
is somehow nothing but a snake pit and
no decent person would ever get involved
and so
you have an abdication of responsibility
on the part of each canadian i would say
which clearly needs to be rectified and
then
this isolation of the political class
from the population that
that's that's replaced by a reliance on
hypothetical experts in the medical and
the political domain and sampling of of
the public
attitude by opinion poll this is not
a recipe for a stable polity as as we
can see
sure you mentioned before we started
recording we were just chatting that we
are going to be
dealing with this kind of situation for
a long time
uh what what are the implications if we
lose this fight
well i don't know what it would mean to
lose it i mean i can't see how the
mandates can go on forever
country after country is dropping them
i cannot see how they can be sustained
in the face of that for any length of
time but god only knows i mean it seems
to me that
perhaps even a majority of canadians if
they were sufficiently cowed
would accept these restrictions
and mass mandates
permanently it's already been two years
and a huge there's a huge public outcry
although it's hard to tell what the
proportions are against the truckers and
in favor of what continued mandates well
they're afraid i remember there was a
poll a few months ago
showing that 50 of democrats in the u.s
thought there was a 50 chance of being
hospitalized with covid
and and 25 of republicans believe the
same thing and i'm sure that proportions
are very similar in canada people are
afraid and the politicians should be
coming out and saying
we got this like there's always things
to be afraid of but that isn't what's
happened
um
if the if
i i really have no idea how how this is
going to go i think what will happen is
that
a few provinces will
carefully test the public opinion waters
which seems to be happening say in
saskatchewan and alberta and say well
here's
a way out in a month how's that settling
and if that works out they'll say well
maybe we'll try it in two weeks
something like that and if that happens
maybe there's a pathway forward
but our prime minister could easily
double down because
he has the
he's a he's a teenager he's a he's a
teenage actor fundamentally the fact
that he ran away at the beginning of
this and then lied about why in two ways
security concerns and exposure to kovid
it's like a little convenient i would
say and really did you need two lies to
justify it wasn't one enough
apparently not and the fact that he ran
away at all is just also
jaw-droppingly jaw-droppingly
stunning to me it's like does he believe
that matter to so many people i mean i
think it's starting to matter to more
and more but why don't people look at
that look at that fear and cowardice and
call it out for what it is and then why
are they not afraid of not having a
leader i think it's easier for them to
believe that the truckers are dangerous
like confederate rebel dangerous
whatever the hell that means in canada
nazi dangerous
this whole nazi thing is just beyond
comprehension it's
canada doesn't have a radical right wing
well i think it's easier for people to
believe
that the truckers are
january 6th level insurrectionists
than it is for them to believe that they
have a leader who is that immature and
cowardly because we think about i mean
both of those are those are both nasty
pills to swallow but if you're
a
middle-of-the-road canadian and you've
had an implicit belief in the stability
of your political institutions which is
reasonable because they've been increa
incredibly stable you believe in the
general goodness of your leaders which
has also been a valid presumption
and now you're forced to swallow this
pill which is no things are so bad that
your leader who's a teenage
actor literally ran away in the face of
some political opposition or these
people can't be trusted well obviously
it's much easier to believe that the
truckers can't be trusted
and then that's played up of course in
the media it's like well what about the
swastikas and what about the confederate
flag and
and people also still trust ctv they
still trust cbc especially older people
and it's no wonder they do because once
you could and they're not up on the
technological revolution and no bloody
wonder because who is
and
so people are being asked to abandon
faith in some sense in political
establishments and political leadership
or demonize the truckers well it's not
surprising they
they they pick the ladder do you think
people like living in fear in some sense
i mean i guess in a way that sounds
crazy why would anyone want to live a
fearful life but as you have said for
two years we have voluntarily pretty
easily agreed to all of these mandates
in the absence of really any kind of
solid evidence to support them i mean
now we have a situation the practical
upshot of all of this is you can be a
symptomatic cobit positive person dining
in a restaurant
while an uninfected unvaccinated person
is waiting outside to pick up their take
out order
right
and yet it seems like
many most i don't know where we're at in
terms of the numbers feel like well
that's all right that's i don't i don't
think people like living in fear but
they like to believe that they're on the
side of compassion and security when
uncertainty and threat lose and so
that's the moral and it's it's an easy
moral victory
remember i used to watch the simpsons
all the time and the wife of the
reverend on the on the simpsons her
response to any political question was
think about the children let's think
about the children and that's
and our whole society has slept has
slipped into that kind of eatable virtue
which is it's a reflexive infantile
compassion
and there's a presumption underneath
that that it the manifestation of that
compassion which is appropriate for
infants is the only valid political
response to every single question and so
you you frighten people and the good
thinkers the maternal good thinkers
think oh well security and safety
protect the infants and fair enough
because you've got to protect the
infants but we're not infants or are we
and so our whole political discourse is
is warped by that strategy safety right
we have this pure culture this safe do
you think that's historically
unprecedented are we more obsessed with
it yes
definitely
why is that why because of the
large-scale movement of women into the
political
sphere
that's a huge part of it because women
are more agreeable than men and so
compassion for them is a
what is an easier moral
uh
it's it's the easiest moral option
that's available and this is a real it's
a real struggle right because how much
you should push forward bravely and how
much you should secure the home front
that's a constant question but we have a
we've had a mass movement of women into
institutional and political arena
and
so that's one element of it that we
haven't contended with at all and no one
will even ask the question and then
there's another issue that's that's
relevant to this too is that
um
the female mode of antisocial behavior
is reputation destruction
like males engage in physical conflict
but that isn't how especially antisocial
males they'll use physical dominance as
a well as a mean to obtain their narrow
self-interested goals that's a bully and
bullies become criminals that's not the
female antisocial pathway the female
antisocial pathway is gossip
maliciousness and reputation savaging
and and that there's a very well
documented psychiatric literature
looking at antisocial behavior women i'm
not making this up out of whole cloth
the problem with that is it scales on
social media
so male aggression doesn't
for proximity in some sense our
coveted response is a gendered issue
yes yes well you can see that in the
attitudes the only canadians right now
who support mandates full out are women
over 55 and i think yeah well they'll
wonder that's what a grandmother should
do you know
because what you're suggesting i think
and correct me if i'm wrong is that
things like compassion and empathy which
seem morally good or morally neutral
maybe morally good uh
are sliding into this safety obsession
which have really become a kind of
myopia right because it's made us focus
exclusively not just on harm avoidance
but on a certain kind of harm avoidance
in a certain sphere and that has
generated these mandates that have the
appearance of protection which can't
help but sound good yeah that's right
that's right
that well absolutely well and and
who could you possibly be to oppose that
you know even what makes you so sure
you're not a predator i mean you and i
have both been called evil so yes yes
well well and that is part of that
that security feminine security response
now i'm not blaming women for this this
is a very complicated problem but
the
that which
threatens the integrity of an infant is
a predator
now the question is what what happens
when that scales now the psychoanalyst
said this is a freudian idea the good
mother necessarily fails
and that's that's exemplified by michael
angelo's pieda that's like a symbol of
the female crucifixion it's to offer
your children to be broken to the by the
world
and that's a major sacrifice on the part
of women it's a major yeah right
absolutely absolutely and that's
that just gives me chills because yeah
well
it's like it does evoke those kind of
those feelings of the very unnatural to
think that you wouldn't
yeah well but but the alternative is to
devour them
right that's that's the freudian
nightmare it's like you don't
if you don't propel your children out to
the world so you're the supporter of the
call to adventure which is terrifying
it's terrifying
my my daughter-in-law
she uh
she was with her son
elliot for
18 months
and then she went back to work and she
made arrangements with a woman who had a
couple of little kids in daycare
and she
brought elliot to daycare and
let him off and he was ready for it
they'd prepared him for it but he cried
when she left and she just left
and that's she could have hovered on the
boundary there and tortured him to death
for like three hours right because of
her misery in abandoning her child in
some sense
in the misery of losing her infant
because that's with that mark and then
she went home and cried it's like good
for her she went home and cried
that was the right thing to do not to
demonstrate her
inability to
let go of that maternal attachment when
it was appropriate which is really an
act of
transcendent heroism on the part of a
mother and that's not
that's not that reflexive compassion
that all too often is confused with
moral virtue in our culture the fact
that you feel sorry for people does not
mean that you're good now it might be
one element of what could make you good
if you were good but
that
reflects reflex
isn't it let's let's say that again the
fact that you feel sorry for people does
not mean you're good it's not a sign
that you're good so feeling sorry for
people we might think that that's
empathy
well it is in the it is in the in the
most primordial sense it's what makes
you go off when you see a kitten
you know and and fair enough but
going ah when you see a kitten
on a plate
that's neither a sign of your aesthetic
sophistication nor your moral virtue
and so because more moral virtue is a
multi-faceted phenomenon and this is
also in some sense what the politicians
have forgotten is like follow the
science well
what data and selected by who and which
scientists yeah good luck no kidding
good luck it's such a lie it's a
philosophically shallow light but it
sounds great and we've been conditioned
to believe that that's where truth and
goodness reside science has become a
synonym for
moral purity and perfection well it's
also the case that
it allows the politicians to abdicate
responsibility in the face of a crisis
it's like well we're deferring to the
experts it's like no no
there's no deferring to the experts if
you're a politician there's consultation
with a diverse range of experts that's
that's a whole different thing it's like
well we're deferring to the physicians
what about the economists you forgotten
about them
what about and that's your talk about
the physicians who disagree with the
sample
certainly
yeah well and the economists always
disagree with the biologists too because
the biologists are always
generally blunt you know vaguely
speaking
most of the malthusian environmentalist
types are biologically minded you know
oh my god the sky is falling
well the economists say no we can we can
innovate our way around this like we
have in the past and we don't have any
obvious limit to resources and there's a
real
argument to be had there what are the
limits to
economic growth and prosperity are there
any where are they located well this is
a real argument but the idea that you
can defer to the biological
catastrophists is an abdication of
political responsibility and
self-destructive most likely well
well you
everybody can watch for themselves just
watch what happens to energy prices in
the in europe
just watch and just watch what happens
to poor people because it's coming and
fast i think one in 10 people in the uk
have already received at least one
disconnection notice from their
utilities one in ten
so
you know and in canada the same
reflexively compassionate
popinjays
are going to war on so the fundamental
basis of the western economy you know
the oil and gas industry are we going to
see
greater disparity between the upper and
lower classes higher levels of
homelessness
higher levels we're certainly going to
see greater all that all the covet
policy has driven immense amounts of
capital to a small proportion of people
i mean everyone knows this
how many houses were
had so much cardboard they could hardly
even figure out where to store it
because of amazon purchases
now amazon sells everything and you know
in some sense hats off to jeff bezos
because look at the supply chain that he
managed to keep
going under dire conditions during the
pandemic but on the other hand every
cent he made in some sense was taken
from small business people
and we've decimated the small business
community
and to think of that as somehow less
dangerous than the pandemic is utterly
foolish i i think i think the move that
was made this week to scuttle
the gofundme funding for the truckers is
more dangerous to our collective health
than the pandemic just that one move
we'll see
can you explain that a little bit why is
that so dangerous to our health
collective health because the government
just colluded with a a corporation to
steal money from citizens who were
expressing their politically and
efficiently no problem no discussion no
problem
with a moral overlay well we're going to
give it to approved charities they
didn't even say they would refund the
money now you can ask for your money to
be refunded that's real nice eh so
someone mugs you says well
if you ask me i'll give you it i'll give
it back to you it's like how about you
don't steal it to begin with or if you
do that you just return it
or the mother says i don't approve of
what you were going to do with that
money i have a better idea for it yeah
yeah
we talked about gendered aspects of this
mandate situation earlier but can we
talk about race for a minute
because it's this uh protest situation
in ottawa
and those challenging the mandates have
been accused bluntly blatantly of being
racists
why
why did we get there so quickly is that
just a scapegoat the race issue
well i no it's not just a scapegoat i
think that
the fundamental contention of the
radical left and so i would include
the forces that are
pulling justin trudeau's strings in a
philosophical sense and in a practical
sense to some degree but certainly
philosophically because he's possessed
by a set of ideas
he's the partial avatar of a very
destructive set of ideas
and when push comes to shove those ideas
control his thoughts
and so
the fundamental contention of the
radical left is that
there is nothing but power that
motivates discussion and categorization
and speech it's all the war of all
against all and we divide ourselves into
our various power-based hierarchies
racial ethnic
gender sex age and then we fight like
mad for our individual selfish dominion
within each of those domains and so
there's no
place for the supposition that the
opposition might be
the honorable opposition right where
you're both united in a polity that
allows for discourse there's merely the
accusation that
you're playing a naked power game
because that's what everyone does
and that's the fundamental contention of
the radical left is that the act of
categorization itself it's the
presupposition of the implicit
association test that the act of
categorization itself so that that upon
which discourse itself relies is nothing
but the manifestation of the corrupt
will to power
and this
categorization is diffusing isn't it as
soon as you accuse someone uh oh you're
just a that you're just a racist you're
just a misogynist you're just a
confederate whatever it is
um it does seem to pull the rug out from
under them
well well well
well
it really pulls the rug out from
underneath
all of them who aren't that
see if you are that let's say you're a
psychopath and then for you
the will to power is everything in the
narrow sense that's about three percent
of the population it's not a very
effective adaptive strategy by the way
the naked expression of power doesn't
work for chimpanzees it doesn't work for
rats it certainly doesn't work for
people that whole
idea that it's nothing but power that
mediates the relationship between human
beings is not only ethically appalling
in the deepest possible sense it's also
scientifically unjustifiable it's simply
not the case but
if it was the case so let's say you
accused me of that and i am that it's
like you think i care about your
accusations it's like you're not making
me feel guilty psychopaths don't feel
guilt
now the people you will make guilty with
an accusation i'm sure you experienced
this when people came after you it's
like the first thing you do
if an angry mob goes after you is you
think if you're a reasonable person you
think
well i probably am a little racist and i
probably am a little sexist and i
probably am a little uncautious with my
words and all these people are angry and
so maybe i said something wrong and so
then you scour your conscience it's like
gad saad in his recent video which was
quite comical he showed himself whipping
he's whipping himself with a whip
self-flagellating apologizing for being
a friend of mine and obviously he was
doing it satirically but there's a
there's a truth in it which is when the
mob comes after you and accuses you of
nothing but
motivation
by the desire for naked power well
there's a part of you that is like that
and so if you're a conscientious person
you're going to retreat and you're
likely going to apologize in which case
you're just dead
did you ever apologize did you or did
you what happened with you apologize for
what well that's the cool for whatever
you were being accused of
i never apologized for
um
refusing to comply with my university's
mandate
i never apologized for speaking publicly
about it
i never have and won't apologize for
continuing to try to have discussions
about the truth that doesn't mean that i
or who i'm talking with will will always
get it right surely we'll make mistakes
everyone makes mistakes
the truth isn't a set of facts the truth
is an approach to dial to discussion
that's what joe rogan's so good at
that's why he's so popular it's not
because joel
knows the truth it's because he acts out
the truth
in his in his in his in his speech and
his actions
so
yeah that's a whole different thing
whole different thing um one of the
things that's deeply troubling but so
interesting to me is how things that
seem to be so fundamentally canadian i
mean literally
encoded in our fundamental documents
like our charter of rights and freedoms
our constitution our freedoms and rights
the language of freedoms and rights
but now if you invoke these in
discussion or to make an argument you're
accused of
taking advantage of your privilege
what do you think about that is is it
impossible i mean is it wrong in a
democracy like canada to talk about
freedoms and rights is it impossible to
be
unprivileged in talking about them no
the matter is not
well well that's that's where the
discussion should really focus okay so
let's talk about privilege okay so
you're accusing let's say you're
accusing me of privilege
okay well
you too
let's talk about you too so for i was at
this gathering once in l.a it's really
quite comical it was in an extremely
rich gated neighborhood and they had a
big enough lawn so it was like a forum
and the speaker came out and talked
about the one percent who controlled
everything and how appalling that was
and how we should be how
good thinking people were on the side of
the oppressed and i was looking around
like it was in
a deli painting it's like what the hell
and so at the end of this speech and
everyone was clapping way i stood up and
said i don't know if you guys noticed
but you are absolutely
in the one percent like beyond any
possible doubt
not only in the united states
in all likelihood you're in the one
percent but if you look at your position
globally it's more like one tenth of the
one percent so what the hell are you
talking about
it's like so let's talk about privilege
well
every single person on the planet has
is delta an arbitrary hand
in some sense and some of that is
unfair burden
the natural lottery is john rawls bets
natural lottery and some people
some people are dealt a pretty rough
hand although it's not evident a
priority who's dealt the roughest hand
you know now sometimes you meet people
and you think oh my god object you know
yeah it's all threes it's really not
good and and that is painful for
everyone but
but but and so everyone has their
unearned advantages and their unearned
disadvantages
everyone so first of all we universalize
that we say yeah we all have unearned
privilege it's like original sin it's
very much like original sin
and then the question is well you have
to understand and then you say well
there is a moral burden that comes along
with that
you have privilege and advantage that
you didn't earn it's it's given to you
it's a set of talents let's say and the
gospel commentary on that is to those
who are
to those
to whom much has been given
much will be demanded
and that's actually although it's a
warning
and it's a
it's a
uh
what you call it's a moral injunction
yeah but it but it's also an escape
route
you see because
because we have everything we have this
field of opportunity in front of us and
because some of that is unearned
we have an existential moral obligation
to atone
and what that means is that we have to
use the unearned privilege that we all
have
in a manner that's so good
that we can say
yes i was granted these gifts but look
at how i've multiplied them
and you need that
not because you should be good although
you should be it's because you will
become the victim of your own conscience
if you don't do that and then when the
mob comes after you
you will fold because they'll say you
don't deserve what you have and the part
of you that thinks
i'm not really living up to my
possibility it just it breaks you in
half
is inevitable to criticize it is just to
criticize a natural fact of nature in
some sense but there's a question if i
understand you that if there's a i mean
privilege gives you certain rights
certain entitlements certain advantages
but with those come responsibilities so
you don't get commensurate
you know at all and and everyone who
thinks this through for 15 seconds knows
that it's like you don't think you call
yourself out on your moral shortcomings
you do it all the time and and if
someone pokes you there and you're weak
because of that you'll fold and the left
particularly the left has become
unbelievably good at using this as a
weapon and part of what i'm writing in
my new book is a chapter on this topic
and defense it's like what's your
defense
live up to the responsibilities
intrinsic to your privilege
because it's the only defense you have
when the mob comes and they will come
they're coming so you have to be able to
say
well i talked to this guy yes a couple
of days ago who uh he's got a
pretty decent fortune you know and so he
wrestles with issues of privilege he's
he's uh distributed sixty thousand two
thousand dollar scholarships
to
underprivileged kids
ninety seven percent high school
graduation rate eighty percent college
graduation rate among the recipients of
the scholarships
it's like
well
when the mob comes for him he can say
hey 60 000 scholarships buddy what have
you done for the world you know and he
shouldn't be doing that in a triumphant
triumphalist manner because pride goes
before a fall but
but
and and what's interesting about him too
is he spent his money once he
accumulated he spent it very carefully
not in judiciously not with a haphazard
compassion right in a targeted
thoughtful
morally appropriate
uh manner so that he didn't cause more
trouble with his money than he
than he uh
saved us from
this is all very difficult
you know the protesters are the ones
being accused of of um
sort of taking advantage of their
privilege by standing up for their and
other people's freedoms but
we're not highlighting the fact that
they're working class people
uh you know walking around speaking with
them they're they're also very tough
people they've been on the streets in
ottawa they've probably been driving for
many days if not a week then they've
been on the streets in ottawa i walked
around and i did an interview had to
hold my phone up but i could last
maybe a minute without my glove on
before the you know the the sharp pangs
start hitting you because it's so
bitterly cold there these people have
been sleeping eating everything outside
round the clock with very few exceptions
uh for
a week now
yeah they put their money where their
boat is what did you say sorry they put
their money where their mouth is right
you know and
yeah yeah well and it's so fascinating
to me as i said before to watch the
privileged elite
leader of the working class response to
this especially on the side of the ndp
because the public polls indicate that
if you vote ndp you're like 75 25
against the truckers and there's nothing
more annoying than uppity working-class
folks
you know as and that's especially true
to the privileged ideologically adult
elites who want to claim moral
superiority over them by leading those
poor sheep into the promised land it's
it's really you couldn't make it up if
you wanted to it's so ridiculous we
don't have to make it up we've seen
these paradigms in literature and
history the greeks were great at this
right i mean we were just we don't have
to make it up we're just copying uh
what's coming before us but i want to
ask you you know you you seem to have
an ability to see
slippery slopes we might call them
better than most you know
how do you think you know when you're at
the top of one of these
precipices pointed downward you know
about to degenerate we might say into
some pretty worse things and what are
the signs of that well i think one of
the
for me one of the signs was
violation of fundamental principles
these principles like the principle of
freedom of speech which is not just one
freedom among many the conservatives
make a huge mistake on this front all
the time because they talk about well
how about
viewpoint diversity
without noticing that now they've made
diversity the superordinate moral
imperative and have subordinated freedom
of speech to that which means they've
lost they instantly lose when they do
that
freedom of speech isn't one freedom
among many and it's not a right
not in any not in the truest sense
it's a necessity and it's a moral
responsibility you're afraid all the
others possible
that's right that's right it's the
precondition for all other freedoms and
it's it you have the right to speak
freely
so that the truth can be investigated
and the truth needs to be investigated
because the truth is very complicated
and it's dynamic in some sense because
the future is different from the past
and so there's a cutting edge we have to
stay on to stay adapted because the
future is literally
not predictable from the past and then
literally entertainment is not partisan
right everyone should be invested in
discovering the truth everyone should it
should matter equally to it it does it
does matter i mean the truth is not
partisan
in that
different partisan stakeholders will
have an ap different a prior
presumptions about which pathway forward
is correct but that's all based on
previous experience
and previous experience is a partial but
not total died and so
the proper way forward literally emerges
as a constant consequence of the free
discourse between
diverse agents
and so
as soon as that's interfered with
the process of thought itself is
interfered with and thought is the
process that
isn't it i mean what's thought for is it
not
the process that adapts us to the
horizon of change i mean that's what
thought does and there's no distinction
between free speech and thought in fact
most of our even our internal thought is
mostly conducted
as a as a variant of an argument or as
opposed to thinking that truth has to be
you know instrumental in order to
achieve some goal we might think even
more fundamentally truth just is an
expression of our essences of being
humans and if we're not doing it or
thought if we're not doing it right
we're not human anymore well the
instrumentality issue is damn relevant i
mean
one of the reasons
when i did this interview for example
and all the discussions i have on my
podcast they're not instrumental
like i didn't come on this podcast
because i thought well i'm going to talk
to
several thousand truckers let's say
and here's what i want them to think and
so i better make sure that i talk in
this manner and i have to make sure i
hit these talking points and there's
none of that
zero and
and because i want to find out what
happens in the moment right we're just
going to have a discussion just i mean
this week this was so comical
so cnn people came after joe rogan and
yes
and and
one of them said
essentially man what's going on here
we've got this whole bureau's devoted to
fact checking and the truth and and all
these experts hired and and
why the hell aren't people listening to
us when they listen to joe rogan and
he's just winging it
and i thought
just winging it eh
you try
just winging it in front of 11 million
people for five years and see if you're
still standing buddy you think just
winging it is so easy well first of all
why aren't you doing it if it's so damn
easy and second isn't it something that
with all
your resources you can only garner like
one-tenth of the audience of one man who
has like zero production
uh
expertise in his studio he just puts it
all out online and all he does is have
honest conversations i mean insofar as
he's capable of that you know joe
stumbles and he knows that and admits it
and sometimes he gets too
you know buttoned down on a given point
but fundamentally he's just trying to do
what we're doing here
leave him alone whoever wants to listen
to joe go listen to joe for goodness
sakes
part of me
part of me now thinks hey
keep at it guys every time you attack
him a million more subscribers for joe
they kick him off spotify he would have
a new platform
like in two days with twice as many
listeners and so joe's got to the point
where as long as he's continues to be
careful and he is being
there i don't think he can be canceled
in fact i think all the attempts to
cancel him
only redown to his credit and increase
the rapidity with which he's destroying
the entire legacy media
this issue of cancelling is so abhorrent
to me in a democracy all of this
legislation that that focuses on you
know hate speech and limiting what can
be said on the internet and what's so
ironic about it is that as you might
know jon stewart mill who was you know
one of the fathers of utilitarianism and
very often invoked in this current sort
of collectivist setting with the with
the mandates right um he himself was an
advocate for free speech because he said
that the problem with squashing free
speech it's not just that you might
learn something new that you didn't know
but you have the opportunity to put your
own beliefs under the microscope and to
think about new reasons why you might
believe or don't believe them so even
on the metric that a collectivist
arguably a a consequentialist a
utilitarian like jon stewart mill is
using
um
cancelling censorship
is not good for humans let alone
democracies that have free speech as one
of their fundamental pillars you know
well the only the only real
rationale for
opposing free speech apart from
ignorance which is that you don't know
that free speech isn't just another
right and you don't know it's
indistinguishable from thought
is the conclusion that you've already
figured it all out
so you don't have to think or you're
trying to
hide something well that that's the
other possibility but those two those
two things go hand in hand very
frequently is that
it's very often that people who are
trying to hide something justify
that to themselves with a kind of
totalitarian certainty about their
beliefs
they double down on them to hide their
own moral iniquities and so
you have to believe
that people like rogan shouldn't be
allowed to just have a discussion with
whoever they want and wing it
and you think that because you think you
already know and you know if your life
is perfect and you're already living in
the kingdom of god and then more power
to you you know maybe you're right and
you can shut down free discourse because
that heavenly heights have already been
scaled
but i haven't met anyone like that yet
most people i know
think
with not too much
thought that there's some things they
still have to learn and some ways their
lives could be improved and
how are we going to approach that
especially you want to find out
how you're wrong
you should talk to people who don't
agree with you
now maybe ninety percent of what they
say is
not worth attending to could easily be
probably the same goes for you
but
ten percent might be just what saves you
in the next crisis
like i've it's one of the things i loved
about being a clinician is that i talked
to lots of people who were really
different than me like seriously
different from me and
if i wasn't learning something from them
when i was in discourse with them it was
because i wasn't conducting the
discourse properly
so they taught me valuable things
even if you don't learn truth even if
you don't learn more reasons for why
your position was right
at the very least you have benefited
from a very rigorous mental exercise
yeah well that helps you as you said
already you want to differentiate and
assess your own beliefs well why well
because your beliefs
aren't a set of facts at your disposal
your beliefs are tools that you use to
navigate the world
and the more finely tuned those tools
more different like
i have a shed at home a shop
with all sorts of power tools in it and
one of the things i learned because i've
renovated houses a number of times one
of the things i've learned is that if
the job is difficult you don't have the
right tool
and then you can go down to home depot
which has like
50 000 square feet of tools which is
just phenomenal and you can find some
little gadget that somebody spent half
their lifetime devising that makes that
job easy well that's that's ideas ideas
are tools they're not they're not facts
and you have to sharpen them and take
care of them and keep them differentiate
them you put them away in the right
way them you bet metaphor is beautiful
you know it seems like so talking about
both both the truckers situation and
then the joe rogan situation it seems in
many respects like intellectuals
or elites have gotten us into this mess
and it's the joke it's the truckers and
the joe rogans of the world that are
getting us out of it arguably
you know what does this say about
education and academia and civil
discourse and democracy moving forward
well it says that the highest and the
lowest always have to be united and what
that means in some sense is that is that
well i learned that in part from
watching wagner's dei meister singer the
opera because he
the libretto elaborates on that theme in
an absolutely stellar manner
it because in his opera
it's the opera
details out the actions of guilds of man
and so each guild is made out of domain
experts so one of the heroes is a
cobbler who's an expert shoemaker you
think well who cares he makes shoes it's
like well
you have good shoes so that isn't a
concern of yours but if you didn't you'd
think it was very important and if
you're a good enough cobbler you get to
sing
and if you're a good enough singer you
get to elect a master singer
it's a lovely structured sequence of
metaphors
and so one of the things wagner did so
well in that opera was to point out that
true expertise means
the differentiation of abstract
knowledge all the way down to the point
of behavioral implementation
and it's one thing i really like about
being trained as a behavioral
psychologist i'm very interested in
psychoanalytic theory but it's very
abstract existential psychology it's
very abstract meaning of life stuff
it's like yeah but where does the rubber
hit the road
well the truckers know that
right they really know that because
they're down there moving goods to
people they're doing the actual work in
the most fine-grained manner now they
might have a problem with high-order
articulation and it's up to their
leaders i'm not so sure about that i'm
not so sure either
[Laughter]
i don't have a challenge every canadian
to get themselves there and talk to some
of these truckers i think they'd be very
surprised they don't have a truck they
don't have trouble with enunciating
blunt truths
but you know you were pointing to
problems among the intellectuals well
the intellectual chattering class is
criticizing the truckers there's a
divorce between the intellectualized
framework ethical framework and that
practical reality that the working-class
people represent
and
i mean your your observation that the
truckers and the joe rogans are are
serving as redemptive agents is a
reflection of the idea of the brilliance
of individual sovereignty the notion of
individual sovereignty as the basis for
political stability it's like well who
should you consult well not just the
people with the ideas
the people who drive the trucks well why
because they're navigating the roads
they're delivering the goods in the real
sense
so they know things yeah you bet well
and are they are the people they have
their families they're they're they're
they're their life is real it's not
abstracted
to the point where the abstractions
themselves become a problem seems like
they're almost like a litmus test for
how we're doing
and the things that we're getting wrong
and they're showing us in the face look
uh it's almost like you know like a boil
that's finally erupting look these these
are the problems right we would have
kept silent if you didn't screw things
up so much but
now we have real problems you're not
fixing them well you saw the same thing
with the yellow jackets in france
it's like corrupt energy policy started
to make energy too expensive for
ordinary people it's like well we have
to save the planet it's like well how
about not on our backs there guys
and so
and we're going to see a lot more of
that i i suspect especially if the elite
types and their utopian schemes
if the elite types with their utopian
schemes keep walling themselves off from
the people that they hypothetically
represent this is why the uk jumped out
of this is why the uk voted for brexit
it's like the common people thought no
too abstract too much of a tower of
babel the leaders have got too far away
from the people they represent and i
think they made the right decision so
more power to rogan than the truckers i
know you're tight on time so i'll just
ask you one last question you know you i
know you're not at a university anymore
you don't talk to classrooms full of
students but now you speak to hundreds
of thousands if not millions of people
when you speak
what do you want to say to canadians now
who are having maybe a hard time
understanding
why the truckers and the people who
support them are
so you know are so committed to this
position what do you want to say to the
truckers themselves
uh to the truckers keep your heads gents
don't take the bait
you know what you're doing
producing a community there cleaning up
the streets trying to care for the
homeless
keeping a playful spirit about this
that's crucial
you know to to do it with this with with
a sense of play that's that's a sign of
mastery it's very difficult thing to
obtain
and
don't let your frustration translate
itself into into violence
be careful be careful be careful there's
a lot resting on what you do every
single one of you yeah yeah so eyes open
like ethical stance forward
caution bravery truth
care
so far the truckers have exemplified the
fundamental
canadian what would you call it ethic of
decency and that's not nothing yeah
there's an ethos the ethos of decency
and
and we're in
times where sudden events can produce
catastrophic consequences
and so keep your heads your if you're on
the side of the right and the good and
the true it will prevail if you can
tolerate the intermediary heat
so don't don't explode prematurely and
keep aiming up man
more power to you
yeah we all need them
jordan thank you so much this is going
to mean an awful lot and we're done here
i'm going to get it in the hands of the
truckers right away and share it as
widely as we possibly can because
there's so much insight and so much
you know you have so much i mean aside
from all of the wisdom
uh you have such an obvious care for
people and for humanity
and i think that's why one of the
reasons why we all respond to you so
much so thank you
could also tell them to be reassuring
and to say because this is what the
politicians should be saying it's like
look
to all of you who are afraid
there is plenty to be afraid of all the
time
but we got this
we got this we can do it we don't have
to let things deteriorate we don't have
to deteriorate into violence and
sectarian squabbling we don't have to
burn down the institutions
right we got this so
so grandmas calm down
clear heads will prevail with goodwill
thank you
you just don't know thank you
very nice to meet you
[Music]
you